Speaker 1: Let's go next to Jack from
Pennsylvania. Jack from Pennsylvania,
welcome. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hello,
David. First time caller here. Here's
a quick hypothetical question for
you. Well, I think I've heard from the
staff like it sounds like a scenario here.
Well, first, actually, do you think it's possible
that if either two parties grow more divided
between like Democrats, for example, progressive
in the moderate camp and the Republicans,
the modern the McCain camp, that it is possible
to see like something like like what happens
in a Whig party in the 1800s where they
the entire party collapses or like the
like splits up into two other parties.
Speaker 1: I do think it is possible, but the very
entrenched system we have for the major parties,
including financing and Commission on Presidential
Debates and all of these other status quo
entrenchment that we have would make it much more
difficult to see what happened to the Whig Party.
It's possible, but I don't see it as likely.
Speaker 3: Okay. And then I guess, like for a
follow up on that question, if it does happen
to one of the other parties, so say literally
magazine and they say, like the Republican Party,
like collapses, do you think it would
be smart for the to progress for the
Progressive Caucus and the Democratic Party?
Speaker 1: Hello. All right. We lost Jack. Jack
was getting to some follow up, but we lost him
with a very strange digital noise right at that
moment. Let's go next to Edward from Colorado.
Edward from Colorado. Welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 4:
Hi there. David, Can you hear me okay?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Okay, so I had a question.
Sure, I do. Some presidential candidates.
Speaker 1: You're cutting in and out, Edward.
You said you had a question about presidential
candidates.
Speaker 4:
About a potential Gavin Newsom candidacy.
Speaker 1: Oh, okay. Go ahead.
Speaker 4: So I guess with him. Do you feel like?
Like the severity of California's COVID lockdowns
would kind of thing.
Speaker 1:
Oh, my God, Edward, you're cutting in and out
with the severity of the lockdowns. Do what?
Speaker 4: Do you think it would be a
substantive enough criticism that it would
hurt him substantially electorally?
Speaker 1: No, I don't.
All right, Edward. The connection is atrocious,
So I'm going to let you go. It's
just. It's very, very, very, very bad.